Восьма ранку у селі Анисів на Чернігівщині.
Для когось тут - це лише початок дня.
Для пані Любові - розпал роботи у рідному дворі.
Ну ось кролики. Це мама їхня.
На! Їж! Он лопає як!
Ну а курочки он у купочку збилися! Ципи-ципи-ципи!
75-річна Любов Прочухан показує нам дрова, які вже наколола на зиму.
А на городі - чекає картопля.
Її одразу передасть через волонтерів багатодітним родинам і військовим.
Я хочу трошки їм допомогти! Як кажуть:
"І мене в сім’ї великій, в сім’ї вольній новій не забудьте пом’янути незлим тихим словом!"
Людина, якщо в неї велика сила волі,
якщо вона проробила усе життя,
не лінилася, без праці не може!
Секрет її праці зараз - жартує пані Любов
- у протезі, що міцно тримає її замість ампутованої ноги.
Оце такий! О! Ну, рік із ним, я вже звикла!
Оп! Заховала від зайвих очей!
І далі працюю! І ходжу - болить, і сиджу - болить!
Хай болить, а я буду робити!
Кожну годину - перерва на процедури.
Оце я побула на городі, тут у мене вже все мокре.
Я скидаю коліно, щоб не натерло.
Ось серветочки, бинтом обмотала.
Про те, що таке протез - Любов Прочухан
геть не знала ще рік тому - навесні 2022-го.
Тоді у березні село Анисів опинилося на лінії оборони
від російської армії під час повномасштабного вторгнення РФ.
Обстріли тривали щоденно.
У нас тут хлопці-волонтери, то я так:
вийшла на вулицю, ага, хлопці стоять.
А воно ж чути, що стріляють, значить, треба робити,
рубаю дрова, зирк - хлопців немає, ховаюся!
Попри небезпеку у рідному селі пані Любов
вирішила щодня доїти корів і готувати домашній сир для односельців, ЗСУ і волонтерів.
Сиру наробила, оце все з молока, наварила-наварила!
Кажу: "Наташо, бери! В тебе там багато дітей, а корови нема!
На молоко, і сир, і м’який сир. Нате вам, дівки!"
Бути корисною саме так жінка обрала невипадково.
Розглядаючи старі фото, пані Любов розкриває ще один свій секрет
- в минулому вона членкиня української команди професійних доярок,
що були призерками СРСР з машинного доїння корів.
Ну було ж таке, було!
Посилали на змагання, було по району перше місце,
по області - так, по Україні - третє місце!
По Радянському Союзу - 10-11 місце!
Саме за улюбленою роботою, якою жінка займалася і на пенсії,
вона ледь не загинула торік під час авіаудару росіян - на сільській фермі.
Я тільки виїхала з сараю на велосипеді,
і проїхала отак до хати цієї, і я впала.
Якби я йшла пішки, в мене б вище коліна не було!
А так, як я була на велосипеді, то мені в кісточку вдарило!
Уже з розірваною ногою на це подвір’я
поранену жінку принесли на руках односельці.
Добрий день!
Драсьтє!
Красуня наша!
Ага!
А сьогодні сюди заходить довгоочікуваний гість пані Любові
- волонтер, який торік з-під обстрілів
евакуював її до лікарні у столиці.
Коли я потрапила у лікарню, звісно, боляче згадувати, але нічого!
Один вечір заходить оцей красунчик і каже:
"Я - Славко! Я вас заберу в Київ".
Любов Миронівна! Привіт, героїня!
Приходить уже ж професор, подивився і каже:
"Забираємо!" Мене - у операційну.
Каже: "Треба ампутувати вам".
Я так дивлюся: я наче і не злякалася, бачу, що сухожилля,
як білі ниточки теліпаються.
І кажу: "Ну, треба, то треба!"
Вона вже на другий день сиділа на ліжку,
я прийшов провідувати її, а завідувач відділення каже:
"Я здивований! Бабуся перенесла наркоз, ампутацію,
але найголовніше - вона позитивна!"
Я їм пообіцяла, що на прощання їм станцюю! Отак!
Це - кадри вже з австрійської клініки,
де відбувався другий етап реабілітації пані Любові - протезування.
На виписці жінка танцювала із протезом на честь лікарів і волонтерів.
Небайдужі не припиняють їй допомагати і сьогодні
- зокрема, волонтери готуються завершити відновлення обстріляної хати пенсіонерки.
Утеплення стін фасаду і утеплення покрівлі. Два фасади вже утеплили.
Своєю місією на знак вдячності Любов Прочухан
вважає власний вклад у волонтерство
- зібрану з городу картоплю, м'ясо та консервацію регулярно готує і передає своїм рятівникам,
аби ті віддали нужденним і ЗСУ.
Це сік! Це для вас усе! Огірки!
У селі Анисів  - кажуть місцеві -
Любов Прочухан зажила неабиякої слави -
як волонтерка і мотиваторка для інших.
І танцює! І співає, я вам скажу! І з протезом!
Кого не розпитаєте, всі її знають!
Директорка сільської школи запевняє - популярність активної пенсіонерки
серед благодійників притягує увагу волонтерів
і до проблем самого Анисова,
де нещодавно профінансували відновлення навчального закладу
і будівництво укриття для дітей.
Своєю харизмою вона показала, як можна виходити з найскладніших ситуацій.
Вона старша, це є такий гарний приклад всім нам.
Не приховує свого бажання далі допомагати іншим
та надихати їх і сама пані Любов.
Вийду в город і я радію сама собі:
і те в мене є, і те в мене є.
Є і з руками, і з ногами, кажуть: "В мене нема!".
А у мене все є!
Хто в таку ситуацію потрапив - не здаватися!
Треба набиратися сили волі, во!
І не падати духом: а я можу, а я буду! І все!
Невдовзі на пенсіонерку чекає повторне протезування
і подальша реабілітація, каже волонтер В’ячеслав.
Втім, до лікарні жінка не поспішає, доки має хатні справи.
Славко, переробимо тоді, коли я докопаю картоплю, усе зроблю!
А тоді будемо протез міняти!